ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
rentré d'étrangers quinzaine de jours
merci madame treacle bunk passé une
délicieuse journée
à bientôt vous inquiétez pas c'est est
rien
tout va bien c'est qu'une bagnole qui a
raté
paraît que ça finit par passer
[Musique]
je te demande seulement de revenir
revient en un seul morceau
je fais toujours le même cauchemar jus
pur
mais aucun son ne sort de ma bouche
dans ce pays la loi ont leur appartient
pas quand je pense à la ferme je pense à
la boue aux croûtes qu'elle nous laisser
dans les cheveux c'est notre ami qui
sera dans le pétrin
tu comprends ça tu comprends
c'est quoi le pire truc que tu aies
jamais fait du trail ton propre sang
tu vois même pas ta femme est
malheureuse réduit au silence
l'oppression
il faudra un homme extraordinaire pour
surmonter tout ça amen